Jennifer in the meantime is from
Minnesota hi Jennifer how are you - I'm
fantastic thank you for taking my call
and changing my family I'm honored you
changed your family I just showed you
how you're the hero how can i I'm in
kind of a pickle and I have searched all
your podcasts and I cannot find you
talking about disability student loan
discharge I have already applied for
this the school helped me actually kind
of crazy and then afterwards they told
me that there is a three-year post
surveillance period where if I get a job
and I basically make any type of money
they call it under the poverty level
here for two people which is basically
any amount of money I almost didn't once
come back plus the interest that I
didn't pay on them no because you
weren't permanently disabled exactly but
they're still trying to push me into
doing this I'm just not sure what to do
because I was only disabled I don't know
yet I want to say no I won't write again
or you want to say sorry
yeah I would take it really and then if
you're if you you know if you if you go
back to work then your student loans are
there if not they're gone okay and if
you go back to one well just tell just
put them on you know will revert to baby
step to knock out student loans how much
they loaned out have you got seventy two
thousand dollars when you were working
what did you earn I end about 42 years
doing what I was a bookkeeper and a
general manager for our office what's
the nature of your disability
I got Lyme disease and it took him four
years to find it yeah I lost one we lost
one of our hands off the staff here he's
on out on long term disability the same
thing and it took him five years to find
his yeah that he thought he was just
lazy because he felt like crap all the
time and yep I felt like crap all the
time I had memory issues
like having the flu for five years so
buddy wasn't lazy he was just hurting
anyway and in that process I lost my
home I lost my vehicle while I was
trying to figure out what was wrong with
me because everybody else just thought I
was lazy too and then my kids and dad
passed away as well all in a four year
period well I'm sorry you're really
hearing aren't lis receiving SSI two
forms I get 771 SSI for myself and then
I get 980 for my son whose father passed
away that's benefit you get that whether
you have disability or not ok right the
Lyme disease are being treated right
it's being treated but it's a long
process being treated for Lyme disease
from oh and then I'm like am I going to
get 100% better and they're basically
throwing their hands up in the air and
saying we don't know right and so for me
it felt like when I was doing a
discharge thing like agreeing to be
disabled for the next three years
does that make sense yeah cuz you are
but you're also saying if I get better
we're going to praise God and pay 72,000
off I would gladly take the 72,000 back
if your health returns in return for
your right right because the interest on
this is just astronomical
I have 46,000 I actually took out in
loans and the 26 is just the injured
three years of interest is not that much
okay
it's probably another six thousand bucks
okay less scary yeah I mean think about
your interest rate five point five okay
so that is three thousand dollars a year
okay that is a lot less scary okay cuz I
was thinking it was gonna be like 26
over the three years again no point oh
five times 72 okay it's 3,000 okay all
right and so that's your interest rate
and that's that's the interest accruing
per year so about ten thousand a year
or 10,000 over three years if you go
back to work any time during that time
if you go back to work after three years
it's still forgiven correct Wow okay so
we just continue the treatments I don't
know I'm not a medical expert and I
don't you know I don't know what your
prognosis is going to be the only times
I've had experience with it is the one
guy that worked here and I knew one of
the guy that had it and so and it's been
a bit of a slog for both of them to
return to health and I suspect you might
have a three year window to get back to
health and if you have a two year in six
month window you stay out of work for
six months and let this go by and then
you get back to work even if your health
returns don't go back to work with two
months left on the three years to run
and blow the whole thing up
let's sit there for two more months and
let it go by and because that's what
it's for
that's how it's designed and you're not
lying and you're not cheating anybody or
anything like that but if I mean but if
after a year you're ready to go back to
work and you you have to get the student
loan debt back well fine we had it set
aside if things went bad but they didn't
go bad they went good and so you're back
to work and take it on and knock it out
yeah yes I would take the deal because
of the way we're talking through it here
after walking through the kind of the
critical thinking the worst case
scenario best-case scenario and you look
at the actual math and put all the
pieces on the table to make the decision
with and that's how I would do it so hey
good question I'm sorry you're facing
this I know that's been a tough run for
you and living on sixteen hundred bucks
a month there's no picnic with a baby so
especially when you don't feel good all
right we're gonna put you through
Financial Peace University as our gift
to help you walk through this if hold on
and while Kelly pick up and get that
done for you